today is January 22nd 2023 and this is
the 23rd year anniversary of my mom's
death
she died down in Costa Rica and I
actually didn't learn about it for about
two days I'll tell you about that in
just a bit but you know I I got to
thinking about this I saw a Facebook
memory that was a reminder and I was
like oh yeah it's that day again because
in the Facebook memory I said if it
wasn't for Facebook reminding me I would
have like forgotten about this because
it's always at the busiest time of the
year when the semester is underway and
all sorts of other things are happening
but here it is once again every year and
this is kind of an interesting one you
know she died in in 2000 very early on
so just across the you could say the
threshold of the New Millennium and she
was 53 when she died if she lived till
April she would have been 54. I'm going
to be turning 53 this year myself and so
there's a long distance and I thought I
would do some reflection sort of like
what I did in the video about growing up
you know without my dad because he died
when I was 11 and he was only 36. but
this is a little bit different because I
got to know my mom quite a bit in my
let's call it my early adult life and I
probably just as with my dad would have
benefited considerably having them
around much longer and of course it
would have been good for them as well
they missed out on a lot of
opportunities getting to see you know my
kids
getting to meet you know my my wife and
you know getting to know her and her
family and all of that sort of stuff
so you know I've got a bunch of
Reflections here but I should probably
tell a bit of the story and I should
also make a clarification that'll be
necessary for some people so when I say
my mom I mean Monique Sadler who was
born Monique Claudette lamris and then
married my dad Anton Sadler when they
met while both of them were in college
she was at DePaul down in Chicago one of
the first people in her family to go to
college and she met him up at UW Madison
she dropped out they got married they
couldn't have kids even though they
tried and so they adopted me and then
later on they adopted my sister from a
different family she's about two and a
half years younger than me and when I
say mom and dad I mean My adoptive
parents because they were the ones I
grew up with and I was quite fortunate
in who who I got because you know my dad
was a great guy my mom was a great woman
and her larger lemre's family was very
important in my life and my sister's
life and our development and all of that
I do have you know a biological uh
mother and father and I'm in touch with
my my biological father I was in touch
with my biological mother for a long
time and what I can say is holy crap am
I glad that she gave me up for adoption
because my you know my life is so much
better having had the parents that I did
the only drawback was of course that
they died so young so
with my mom uh what ended up happening
was I was down in Southern Illinois I
was in graduate school living in a
trailer park you know paying a pretty
cheap rent and
um I got a call from the U.S consulate
in Costa Rica and and you know back then
uh you didn't have phones that I
actually told you who it was or anything
like that so I answered the phone and
it's the middle of a cold winter and you
know they said are you Gregory Sadler
and and you know it's a woman on the end
of the phone and she was I think the
console or perhaps you know the
subconsul or somebody like that and she
said well I've got some unfortunate news
for you there was a terrible rafting
accident and your mother is dead and uh
We've you know we've got her remains and
we need to know what you want us to do
and she was down in Costa Rica
um they were on a rafting trip trip and
it was her and five other people
including her boyfriend at the time her
live-in boyfriend and
um
the you know the the river was swollen
from rains nobody really should have
been on the river there were all sorts
of things in the background this company
that they were going with had been
previously written up for safety
violations uh my mom that day we know
from her travelogue that she did not
want to go on the river that day and we
also knew this from one of her friends
who she'd confided in her boyfriend
insisted and
um there was an accident and not only
she died but another person drowned as
well and uh my mom's boyfriend his son
was on the trip he got a broken arm and
they were in the middle of the Jungle so
the Red Cross had to go in and recover
the bodies and help the others who were
pretty busted up as well and it took an
entire day to get them out of the Jungle
so imagine some Red Cross person with uh
you know my mom and there was another
person a guy who died strapped to their
backs carrying them out of the the
jungle down trails and uh you know the
the the consul said listen we're going
to issue some some death certificates to
you
um you're gonna need them for all the
things that you're going to have going
on in the next you know week months
ahead and
um we're gonna have to cremate her
because there's no way we're shipping a
body you know from Costa Rica all the
way up to Wisconsin
um the embalming processes down here are
a bit different than they are in the
states and I was like yeah that sounds
that sounds quite reasonable and so then
I was like you know I got off the phone
and I was I was people say oh you're in
shock or something like that and I'd
imagine to myself what would I do
hearing the news of my mom dying and I
pictured myself like you know knocking
books off the shelf or something like
that didn't happen instead I was like
well
what am I going to do and
I had a girlfriend at the time who had a
working vehicle because otherwise I
would have had to like immediately get
on the Greyhound and go up north my mom
had recently bought a new house she'd
been living in a place called Menomonee
Falls for quite a while she sold that
and bought a house in Brookfield in a
fairly nice subdivision you know I'd
been there a few times and uh you know
we'd had a family Christmas there at one
point and so I knew I had to get up
there so we pile into my girlfriend's
um uh not quite SUV one of those kind of
little hybrid things that had a canvas
top and all that and we'd get on the
road for the seven hour trip up to my
mom's house in Brookfield and it was
super cold you know we had blankets
along fortunately and I was just kind of
you know thinking well what what
happened and what do I need to do next
my sister
my younger sister was I think six months
pregnant at the time and
um
I don't remember if she was married or
not I think maybe she was to her uh the
guy that she was seeing at the time when
she you know later on got divorced from
and I knew she wasn't going to be any
help whatsoever but they didn't have
quite so far to go they were just up in
the Fox Cities so maybe an hour hour and
a half Drive
so it's you know by the time that we get
there I mean I got the call in the
morning and what I remember is getting
there and it being dark and uh you know
finding the key I forget exactly where
it was stored like in a you know under a
little owl statue or something like that
and getting inside and
um
you know then my mom had bought these
two little tiny pug cats and they came
running up and uh you know they're
wondering who we were and you know we
get in and start unpacking and just
going through stuff there was so much to
do all these people in the family to
call and let know what was going on I
mean I didn't have a cell phone at the
time uh because I wasn't You Know Rich
or anything or a techie and uh you know
uh it was calling from my mom's place
and you know then in the following days
there were all these things to handle
including her boyfriend coming back
bringing the the urn acting like a
jackass uh you know lighting candles in
the bathroom that caught a towel on fire
he was just kind of a hot mess but he
was always kind of a screw-up and then
they were you know my family my mom's
family started showing up and uh you
know sort of camping out as fortunate
she had a big place with lots of rooms
and I started going through
some of the paperwork and there was all
sorts of stuff to to handle and then we
had to think about the funeral
and you know I know I'm presenting this
in kind of a disjointed fashion I'm just
remembering all the things at the time
so you know one of my memories is of
going to one of the local churches and
my mom you know she had grown up
Catholic and then you know she was in it
when it was very doctrinaire and strict
the Baltimore catechism days and then we
had Vatican II and things kind of opened
up and she had
um you know been
involved in the church for quite a while
and then you know kind of
straight away you know and so she wasn't
a member of any of the parishes she
wasn't on the rolls and I remember going
to this this church and I was like Well
we'd like to have you know a funeral
mass for my mom
and the priest said well she's not on
our parishioner roles and I was like
well she's not on anyone else's
parishion or roles either and you're the
closest church so what do you think
they're going to say if I walk into
there somebody's gonna have to do this
why not you and and that you know
convinced the the priest and they were
able to do that you know and we we did
the
Mass we did the Wake it's interesting
too because my mom at the time she was
working for a tombstone Pizza which then
got bought out by Craft RJ Nabisco and
she you know at one time she was working
for the general manager and then she
started working in HR and my mom was an
incredibly uh outgoing gregarious person
really the life of the party a little
bit manic as well and a real go-getter a
real people person as as you say so
there were lots of people who came to
the funeral from her work and my family
I would say at least 100 people showed
up uh from that and then there were our
local friends but the bulk of the people
were from the Vagabond ski club which is
an organization in the Milwaukee area
and there's probably vagabonds in other
places as well
and it was basically for like middle
class on upward people who were widowed
or divorced or things like that and they
did ski but they also did all sorts of
other things as well vacations and you
know uh trips to different places and it
just so happened that at the time she
was the secretary for the club and so
word got out and I would say about a
thousand of those people showed up and
so the receiving line for the funeral
this is all happening not on obviously
the 22nd but about a week later really
um we were there for six hours we
actually had to like at certain points
take a break you know go off for 10
minutes and a receiving line is you know
the immediate family so you know me and
my girlfriend and my sister and and uh
her her husband or boyfriend at the time
my aunts and and uncles you know my
grandpa and grandma
and uh
you know we're all there and people come
up and they say their thing the best
people are the ones who just say
um sorry for your loss and then get the
hell moving right you don't want to hear
a big long story about how they know
your mom or something and the Vagabond
ski people a lot of them said crazy crap
you know like oh she's an angel in
heaven looking down on you or you know
she's in a better place and after a
while I was like well how the hell would
you know that you know I mean if you
actually believe in this stuff she could
be in heaven she could be in hell
um people don't become Angels you know
at a certain point I got kind of tired
of that especially when I heard this
this one crazy lady telling me about
like Elijah's twofold spirit and some
crazy application to my mom's case so
you know there was all that going on and
then we had to like start looking at uh
her retirement account which paid out to
my cousins and the life insurance and
you know there was a will interestingly
in her previous will she had actually
because she knew how much I disliked her
boyfriend she had a Proviso that I had
to give him a certain amount of time
before kicking him out of the house
right it's clearly aimed at me not at my
sister who was a bit more sanguine about
those sorts of things or rather passive
and in this case uh you know there
wasn't anything about the new house
um but you know there's a lawyer's names
the the chandex husband wife team so I
looked them up and made an appointment
with them and I was like what happens
next I've never done this sort of thing
before
and uh there was a lot to go on with
that and you know throughout all this
you know there was the The Grieving the
thinking about what had happened you
know her last moments she drowned to
death
we didn't know all the particulars about
it but you know I I it's interesting
because she almost drowned to death just
a few months before on another white
water rafting trip she was telling us
about it at our family Christmas down in
Indiana
and she was telling us this scary story
about how like the Wrath flipped and she
was stuck under a log and she was
thinking to herself this might be it and
you know somebody pulled her out and and
so she was saved and we're like this is
really dangerous why are you doing this
well you know she was always kind of a
thrill seeker she was always into
Adventure I don't think she thought a
lot of the time about
the possible uh dangerous repercussions
of things until after they they happened
and so you know there's all that and you
know I'm almost the same age that she
was when she died and I I think of
myself as like being solidly within
middle age and it's it's interesting to
look back on because that's where she
was and she was so active and vibrant
and and interested in in everything and
then just cut right short she didn't get
to see
um even her her oldest grandchild being
born
um my sister's child she didn't get to
see my kids she never did finish up her
college education you know she worked as
a secretary for one of the Deans at
Alverno College for a while and she was
working on a degree there and then she
left and went to Marquette University
and she worked as a project secretary
and took courses at Marquette and I
think you know at one point in time she
probably probably decided she wanted to
just keep taking as many classes as
possible because when she died her
Alverno credits none of them transferred
to Marquette because they have their own
weird pass fail system so she started
again at Marquette when she died she had
more than enough credits to actually
graduate she'd actually changed her
major several times I think in an effort
to keep from graduating so she could
keep on taking more and more college
classes because you know you got a
certain amount for free and she loved
studying she loved learning she loved
talking about things she was really an
intellectually engaged person as well as
engaged in so many other ways and so you
know there's there's a lot of life that
unfortunately she missed out on
um I don't know I mean now she was born
in 1946 so she would be in her
um you know late 70s at this point
um who knows what she would have
accomplished
um I do know that
had she survived I'm sure she would have
uh really you know loved my my kids
um
and uh you know I'm sure that uh she
would have really enjoyed
um getting to meet my wife and
um her family as well and spending time
together and doing all sorts of things
here in the Milwaukee area and other
places as well but we never know right
because it's it's a blank spot that's
that's left there I do want to say one
other thing too before I wrap this up
you know and it has to do with the death
of my dad
so my mom
uh before my dad died she would work
occasionally and she did a lot of
volunteer sort of things you know she
worked uh for for a while on you know
weekends at JC Penney's in Brookfield at
the Brookfield Square mall and she did
other things like that but for the most
part she she was a housewife but she
wasn't just you know content to be a
housewife she uh was as I mentioned
involved in in many different sorts of
things you know including like our
soccer teams and uh she was a den mother
for Cub Scouts and you know she did
something stuff like that for my my
sister as well with the Girl Scouts and
brownies and
she from early on you could actually see
this by looking at the bookshelf
she knew that I was probably going to be
intellectually gifted and she had all
these books like you know how to give
your child a great mind and you know to
her credit she worked with me as a kid
and by the time that I was three I was
reading my dad handled the mathematics
part she did the you know getting me to
be able to read and then they just
supplied me with books and took me to
the library and on all sorts of
enriching sorts of field trips and
things like that my mom was also an
amazing cook as was her aunt Therese you
know tunny who I've talked about
elsewhere in another video that I'll
link to below and because my dad when he
was alive
he had a really decent job he was a tax
attorney he'd earned both a law degree
and passed his CPA he worked for two
shross here in Milwaukee then he left so
he could take a position as a chief
accountant for a firm in Waukesha that
unfortunately was demanding he cooked
the books so he had to go back to touch
Ross and then he died and he was only 36
when he died and she was only 36 when he
died as well so what you've got is you
know a family where the main Breadwinner
in what was clearly a partnership
between the two of them dies and then
she had to handle all that sort of stuff
herself at you know 36 years old and she
had some support from her family and
from uh you know her her College friends
you know Marcy Butler organized an Irish
wake for my dad but you know she was a
widow with two young kids
that she had to deal with and my dad's
old uh broken down alcoholic father
living you know in our what used to be
my dad's Den upstairs and spending all
of his time in the basement and staying
with us and you know frankly if it
hadn't been for
the you know
um my my grandpa essentially signing
over his Social Security we would have
lost the house and we had to sell off a
lot of the things that we had at the
time you know
um my dad's medical expenses were
significant he'd been at the Mayo Clinic
for for a long time the life insurance
basically covered that and uh then you
know with all the sorrow that she had of
losing the love of her life she had to
go on and go back to work one of our
neighbors who had a office supply store
in Waukesha gave her a job as a
secretary and stalker and then she kind
of you know worked her way from one job
to another
um while trying to figure out what to do
with her life and then you know later on
she began dating again many
not great dates with people and Parents
Without Partners or the Vagabonds she
was involved with a guy who became kind
of a surrogate father for for me Fran
who I've talked about in another video
that I'll also link to below and then
you know moved on from
um from that to date a few other people
and then finally got together with this
Ron guy who everybody knew is kind of a
manipulator and and Gigolo who uh I
remember having a conversation with with
her as we were driving down from Chicago
where she'd pick me up uh with Ron in
the car and all my stuff down to
Southern Illinois University after I was
coming back from uh you know spending
time in Europe and going to graduate
school and she and I were talking in
French because you know she grew up
speaking French before English and I I'm
also you know kind of a half ass
francophone and Ron didn't know any
french and talking with her about
whether she was going to whether she was
happy with him and whether she was going
to leave him and I remember she she had
this sort of view that well you know I'm
in my 50s or I actually would have been
40s then right I I don't know maybe she
was turning 50. um I don't know if I'm
gonna find anyone else
um and I was I was encouraging her of
course but you know to her credit
um she handled a very difficult
situation of her own spouse dying and
not just from some accident but over the
course of months and months that she
spent up at the Mayo Clinic and you know
with two young kids to raise and
literally you know needing to earn an
income to keep a roof over her head and
food on the table and you know we we had
some pretty tough times together
um
so these are just some reminiscence
reminiscences about uh my my mom who's
on the whole a pretty great person had
flaws like everybody else but
was uh definitely a net positive
um and you know she lost her life
relatively early unfortunately she
missed out on a lot that she would have
been very interested and excited to see
I think in the course of her time who
knows what she would have become uh had
she lived longer and uh yeah that's
that's it I'll probably tell some more
stories about her down the line than the
ones I've already told like about you
know learning to cook with her and the
camping trips that we've taken and
things like that that's probably enough
for now to memorialize her in a certain
way